[Music]
we now go to the coronavirus and a quick
look here at the latest numbers from
nevada 147 new cases added in the last
day however 14 more deaths the state's
positivity rate is still dropping though
it is now
4.8 but below that 5 threshold
most of the cases are from here in clark
county the recovery rate though in
southern nevada 96 percent from
the coronavirus nearly 25 percent of all
nevadans have gotten at least one dose
of the covid vaccine
however many are still hesitant to get
the shot a new campaign has started here
in the valley to
increase vaccine awareness in our
minority communities clark county
partnered with grassroots groups and
community organizers with billboard and
social media
the message is simple get your shot when
you're eligible
the more immunity we can create the more
lies we can save and the faster we can
open up our economy
save our small businesses and get people
back to work
african-americans make up about 12
percent of clark county's population
however
only 6 percent have gotten a dose of the
vaccine
advocates say misinformation and a
distrust of the government is feeding
the vaccine hesitancy right now vaccines
are open to anyone in nevada 65 and
older anybody 16 and older with an
underlying health condition
frontline medical workers teachers and
hospitality staff
if you need help making or cancelling a
coronavirus vaccine appointment you can
call the number on your screen
1-800-4010 the number is available from
8 until 8 7 days a week and we have all
the
vaccine information you need at
8newsnow.com